will return it to our coverage of the
earthquakes and the aftermath in turkey
and Syria in a moment but first I want
to bring you some breaking news that's
just come into us here at Sky in the
last few minutes it's come from a tweet
from the prime minister of Canada Justin
Trudeau who has said on Twitter I
ordered the takedown of an unidentified
object that violated Canadian airspace
at NORAD command shot down the object
over the Yukon Canadian and U.S aircraft
was scrambled and a usf-22 successfully
fired at the object the Prime Minister
goes on to say that he spoke with
President Biden this afternoon Canadian
Forces will now recover and analyze the
wreckage of the object and he goes on to
thank Nora for keeping watch over North
America now this is the third
object that has been uh spotted over
North America in just the past week and
remember of course that the US Air Force
shot down this Chinese spy balloon last
week unidentified objects which was
described as the size of a small car was
taken down on Friday and now a third one
taken down over the Yukon the Canadian
Prime Minister telling us that the North
American command taking charge and
bringing that object down and of course
when we get more detail on this third
object flying over North America that
has been brought down by the Armed
Forces there we'll bring that to you
here throughout the evening on Sky News